the question I am most commonly asked
about climate change is should I be
optimistic or
pessimistic I thought about this
question a lot my career has been at the
intersection of climate science
technology policy and Industry mostly
working for you at one point working for
a US president and now as Chief
scientist and chief carbon Wrangler at
Carbon re at that
intersection I think about that question
in terms of energy flows and carbon
abatement options so I Ponder a variant
of that question how much energy should
10 billion people
use I was first prompted to think about
this question by the late great Richard
SMY nanotechnologist Nobel prizewinning
chemist covered Bucky Balls total mench
he gave an important and influential
talk almost exactly 20 years ago in
which he laid out the top 10 challenges
to humanity Energy Water food poverty
the environment health and then said
something kind of
obvious all of these are energy
challenges water is the most
straightforward 34 of the earth's
surface is covered with water it's too
salty to drink or use the primary cost
of desalination is
energy food I like food 80% of the food
consumed around the world moves through
Modern agriculture that means synthetic
fertilizers combines that Harvest
Refrigeration shipping they're all
energy climate that's my day job how do
we go from 54 billion tons of greenhouse
gases every year to less than zero very
quickly and so on abundant clean energy
can make progress against this whole
list so Richard estimated what he
thought it would take for 10 billion
humans to live more or less like like
the United States and his answer
was 60
ter keep that number in your mind 60 for
reference today the world uses about 26
terawatts of energy about 8 terawatts of
that are electricity now the urgency of
climate means that we have
to for all of the energy we use today
and all future energy really has to be
abundant sustainable and
cheap abundant available where you want
it when you want it everybody should
have energy including the 3 billion
people who use less electricity than my
refrigerator
uses however it should also be
sustainable we can't emit a lot of
greenhouse gases we can't trash
nature ideally it's cheap a lot cheaper
than today maybe half or a third of what
the US pays that would be $20 a megawatt
hour or a dollar a
gigle and remember it's energy not
electricity we also need heat for heavy
industry we need clean fuels things like
clean hydrogen or sustainable Aviation
fuels well that seems
hard and it is but if you know that's
what you need or what you want abundant
sustainable cheap energy we have a new
question to ponder how do we get 60 ter
of that to 10 billion
people well the good news is every day
the Earth receives
163,000 ter of energy from the Sun about
half of that bounces back to space but
about 880,000 terawatts arrive at the
Earth in a form we can use for example
the air land and oceans convert some of
that into about
870 terawatts of wind these are bigger
numbers than 60 and we got more than
solar and wind we have geothermal we
have hydro we have nuclear there's other
kinds of clean energies and some of the
best resources are in fact in the global
South these places are not simply future
climate victims these places are latent
energy
superpowers and we've made some good
starts let's look at Chile blessed with
abundant Hydro solar and wind they can
make green electrons on demand a lot of
those green electrons are going to get
turned into hydrogen and ammonia the key
ingredient for fertilizer itself a good
fuel and a great way to move clean
energy around the world now Chile has
prioritized using these green electrons
and hydrogen to decarbonize its own grid
and for domestic energy use for things
like mining they are also building
infrastructure they're building out the
grid and ports for trade and commerce
this prioritization this emphasis on
infrastructure is the difference between
a neocolonial economy and a new economy
built on abundance let's go to
Kenya home of the second most productive
wind farm on Earth in Lake Tana home of
the second largest geothermal program on
Earth and future home of the great
Carbon Valley where this abundant
sustainable cheap energy will create
whole new Industries and pull CO2 out of
the sky now those are good
starts but we have far far to go hash we
need more specifically we need new
investment vehicles and we need
development mechanisms that recognize
the opportunity of abundance
as opposed to being built on the
scarcities of the past my favorite
example Namibia a young rapidly growing
Nation full of Promise one of the very
driest places on Earth Namibia has
excellent solar and wind resources in
particular in the southwest
unsurprisingly a giant 10 billion doll
project is bouldering along that will
land 3,000 megawatt of solar on the
ground 3,000 megawatt of wind that will
feed 3,000 megawatt of electroly that
will make clean hydrogen and ammonia for
export to Europe and European countries
and European Industries are providing
the long-term
off-takes in addition the port of
luderitz is getting an upgrade and
there's going to be jobs and wealth
creation in Namibia I love this
project what's not to like Namibia gets
wealth and jobs Europe gets clean secure
energy
supplies still something's off
that's it this project is 10 times
bigger than namibia's whole
grid and this project will not
substantially build out the
infrastructure or energy access no
refrigerators no new coures a nation now
again this is a great project but how
can we do even better not just here but
everywhere how do we harness abundant
sustainable cheap energy for all well
there's three three ingredients to that
booya base and if you plan to harvest
abundance you act differently in each
first out of the gate
infrastructure we need transmission
lines roads ports railroads fueling
stations we're not moving bits we're
moving molecules and electrons we need
this infrastructure to get electricity
to the people of Namibia and to get
clean fuels out of ports like Mombasa or
C these projects take time money and
people we need to develop the human
capital as part of these investment
projects for decades because remember
children for the rest of our lives every
week is infrastructure
week second out of the gate Innovation
we need much more energy in many places
much cheaper that's an innovation agenda
now all yall are familiar with the
profound and Rapid decreases in cost
associated with solar photo voltaics
that was a combination of sustained
investment in Innovation Plus Market
aligning policies plus Mass
manufacturing for solar that was the
United States Germany China and others
acting together well if that's the
recipe we can do that again we're
already doing it with electric vehicles
and clean hydrogen production we can
certainly do it by turning electricity
into fuels and pulling CO2 out of the
sky in fact the CO2 and clean hydrogen
will be the next generation of
sustainable maritime Aviation fuels we
can go way farther with solar with
perovskites with multi exaton
Technologies like super molecules we can
double or even triple the
output we just had
Fusion in
California now to harness that abundance
an objective should be cost reduction
maybe 50 or even 80% cost reduction and
those objectives should be part of the
goals of the institutions that run
innovation
for example the US Department of
Energy's earthshot programs
third investment specifically we need to
move away from single project Finance to
more systemic investment mechanisms one
that reimagine risk across multiple
projects multiple investment cycles and
multiple years some of the goals of the
audacious and overdue Bridgetown
initiative in addition the full value
chain should be part of the investment
thesis revenues come from many sources
including the infrastructure itself the
equipment sales the new products and the
improvements for Health and Welfare
Global positive investment Global
Positive Growth that yields solid
returns now in the case of Chile Japan
is a key partner and Japanese firms will
make money on turbines electrolyzers
ships infrastructure
debt now one green hydrogen project is
not enough money to do that you need you
know to rebuild shipyards and Supply
chains you need more than one project so
the Japanese government has in fact
backed dozens of projects and these are
anchored by bilateral agreements between
Chile and Japan that include long-term
off takes multiple projects and
long-term off takes change the value
propositions for both countries you're
not feeding a set of shareholders you're
feeding two Nations and Chile has
maintained its commitment to this now
through three successive
governments so let's go back to Namibia
here's the grid today instead of
conventional project Finance for one
project what would a hundred billion set
of projects look like well for starters
you'd sure have to build out the grid a
lot you'd have to add solar and wind
maybe supersize some projects maybe add
some Hydro power instead of temporary
construction jobs in lates you'd have a
permanent construction industry there
and you'd be building electrolyzers all
over Namibia that would anchor Supply
chains across subsaharan Africa and to
train a generation of workers that would
be big enough for desalination bringing
fresh water to the desert into the
communities into the new Industries big
enough for hospitals universities
Regional Logistics hubs big enough to
encourage good governance and best of
all lowcost clean fertilizer that could
be used to make food in Namibia sold
there and to its neighbors in effect
Namibia could be a global anchor for
food and fuel and the investors would
get a solid return now that's a future
to be optimistic about so because let's
be honest whether I'm optimistic or not
the work looks the
same
so let's reimagine that first question
doesn't matter whether I'm optimistic or
you're op optimistic it matters if we're
optimistic Collective action Building
Together is what makes the difficult
possible and nourishes the Soul through
Mission and
purpose and we have a lot to be
optimistic
about infrastructure Innovation and
investment are commitments to the Future
anchored in optimism we also have the
tools and Tech we need we know what to
do
and we can act not out of anger or fear
but out of generosity and common purpose
bringing aspiration and humility
together we're going to build a thriving
vibrant exciting world full of
generosity and full of potential that's
going to be built on the back of
infrastructure Innovation and investment
that will harness the Abundant
sustainable cheap energy that is our
planet's
endowment
thank
you